sur ce plateau régis vient de nous
rejoindre bonjour vous êtes analyste à
géopolitologue directeur exécutif
d'interpol conseil comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer cette augmentation des
attaques contre les chrétiens en afrique
notamment au burkina faso selon donc les
ong portes ouvertes en 2018 cette même
ong avaient déjà alertèrent exactement
on se rend compte que de 2,8 à 2019
la tendance elle est vraiment les a
vraiment elle a vraiment évoluer vers
quelque chose de plus de plus meutrier
etc dont on se rend compte c'est que
cette hausse en fait elle s'explique à
la fois par le fait que les franchises
ou des groupes armés terroristes ayant
perdu du terrain en syrie et en irak
dont se sont déportés sort sur le
continent africain et on trouvait donc
un terreau favorable justement pour
exercer donc ce que ce que je peux
appeler justement et théorise de
localiser et services localisés mais
malheureusement ils frappent
indistinctement mais il mord religieuses
et religieux
mais la focale aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement la plupart de ces
groupes armés terrorisme
retrouvez dans les villes prises dans
les cultes le bon moyen de médiatiser
leurs actions donc quand vous parlez de
cette délocalisation de l'irak de la
syrie vers vers l'afrique vous vous
parlez de du groupe terroriste
djihadiste on parle donc de la mouvance
islamiste
ce qui n'est pas non plus des des heurts
entre aconfessionnel également la
réalité est que bien sûr quand un groupe
armé terroriste frappe mais l'église
frappe un culte protestant ça donne
justement l'impression d'un choc
religieux alors que la réalité elle est
plus elle est plus complexe que ça je
pense que derrière ces causes derrière
une cause de regret la cause religieuse
il ya davantage plus d'écho socio
économique et donc c'est plus un intérêt
donc pour le groupe armé terroriste de
taper une église et taper un culte
protestant parce que plus il sait que
par définition ça va médiatiser son
action et c'est pas la preuve justement
qui est un choc entre autres chrétiens
catholiques ou chrétien protestant
contre des musulmans la réalité c'est
que ces pc c'est peu pour toujours
habité de façon harmonieuse en forme
mais le groupe armé tarifs revêtent
justement l'idéologie
pour davantage médiatisée leurs actions
des actions médiatiques on l'a vu au
burkina faso le week-end dernier on
parle également de la centrafique la
centrafrique assez régulièrement là on
évoque même une possibilité de génocide
au nigeria donc les heurts
confessionnels se multiplient est ce que
ce sont réellement des heurts
confessionnels ou est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
derrière une manipulation politique ou
des phénomènes déclencheurs annexes je
pense je pense et fait des mois qu'on
vous le rappeler hier il ya ce que je
peux appeler quand même une manipulation
de l'information une manipulation de
l'opinion
donc qui tend à prouver que c'est un
choc religion ou une guerre ou guerre
logique qui s'apprête en afrique je suis
passé pour toi vraiment dans ce type de
configuration c'est davantage
manipulation ne part de qui je dois
manipulation à la fois des combats
maîtrise qui souhaiterait justement de
façon effective créer une guerre de
religion ce qui n'est pas le cas
et puis ça permet aussi d'une manière ou
d'une autre à des hommes politiques
quand même de diviser davantage plus est
de faire croire effectivement que le
l'islam est une religion justement qui
aujourd'hui dans ses travers peut
justement porté des coups bas en afrique
alors que c'est pas du tout on est on
est on est dans quelque chose de plus
complexe que ça c'est pas une guerre de
religion c'est pas un chef d'oeuvre un
jour et davantage plus une guerre de
captation de prédation des ressources
économiques de ressources et de richesse
de ce qui fait que justement on peut
retrouver donc des conflits entre des
nomades et des cédantes et entre des
pulls et des haies
on est des dogons mais la réalité elle
est davantage plus lié à des assistés
heureux territoriales à des à des
contrôles sur des richesses économiques
ya pas de guerre religieuse même si
effectivement c'est tout c'est tout
c'est tout l'intérêt pour les groupes
armés terrorisent cas de reuver durée
vêtir comme si vous voulez leur action
quand même de ce sceau de ses sauts de
l'islam moi je pense qu il faut il faut
qu'on fasse très attention
la guerre religieuse en afrique elle
aura vraiment du mal quand même à
émerger parce que de tout temps les
religions ont côtoyé en somme il ya une
véritable harmonie entre toutes les
religions de ce qui fait que on peut
être à la fois protesté au fait musulman
peut être vous dise on peut être raté
donc les religions en affecte
harmonieusement au toujours vécu
ensemble et malheureusement quand vous
l'avez rappelé la hausse est finalement
peu tendre à prouver qu'il ya eu une
espèce de choc religieux qui s'applique
et s'apprête à s'élancer mais ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas
je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse très
attention justement à la tire de logique
qui est utilisé mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que moi j'ai fait convaincu ceux
qui feront davantage plus pour amener la
paix se mettre aussi au temps les
religions et les régies aussi les civils
dans leur gestion en régie
une p quelle est la solution selon vous
est ce que ce sont les pays les
gouvernements qui doit qui doivent
travailler là dessus ou est ce que ce
sont plutôt par exemple vatican où les
différentes patriarcat de
de moscou de costantino par exemple qui
doivent qui doivent travailler là dessus
je pense que la fonctionnelle elle est
plutôt locale vous savez de toute en
afrique
même quand il ya un côté quand il ya un
conflit ou une crise il ya une médiation
et la médiation est très généralement
entretenu les très jeunes et animés par
des chefs de culte
ça peut être ça peut être pris là ça
peut être un imam donc je pense que la
solution elle est très locale le vatican
peut intervenir moi je pense davantage
puisque les imams les curés et les chefs
de culte de culte endogène africains
donc là je suis davantage plus sur la
partie originale dont des cultes
africaines peuvent travailler ensemble
doc c'est la médiation en réalité elle
est vraiment internes et les formats
locale parce que ce dont je suis
convaincu c'est que la victoire la
victoire donc que s'apprête même à
soulever ou les groupes armés théorie
ces corpus d'idées logiquement penser
qu'on est vraiment sur un choc de
civilisations
merci enregistrons paix d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes analyste géopolitologue directeur
exécutif de interglobe conseil merci
beaucoup